bonjour Stéphane Simon bonjour Vincent
que révèle les derniers jours de Samuel
Paty alors on a voulu faire un travail
de fond sur cette affaire Samuel Paty on
a pris le temps c'est la première fois
qu'on propose de reconstituer toutes les
puzzles ou ce que les Américains
appellent la Big Picture c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre le cours
de Samuel Paty et son assassinat 11
jours plus tard c'est donc cette
chronologie avec je dirais une
méthodologie très simple ne raconter que
ce qui est avéré que l'on a détaillé
c'est le fil de ces 11 jours heure après
heure que l'on propose au lecteur et
c'est un récit où on sent le le fil des
responsabilités où on voit préciser le
tableau vous avez eu accès au dossier
j'ai vous avez eu accès à certaines
pièces qui vous ont permis également de
reconstituer ce puzzle on a consulté
beaucoup de s'effectivement on a aussi
fait un travail d'enquête concentrique
vous savez que moi on le sait pas
bien sûr mais j'ai été journaliste de
faits divers j'ai travaillé avec
Dominique Rizet pendant longtemps
pendant trois ans et j'ai appris à faire
ce qu'on appelle d'ailleurs le site
d'investigation factuel factuel.media
exactement et en apprenant à faire une
enquête concentrique on apprend aussi à
faire des enquêtes de voisinage auprès
des collègues auprès des voisins auprès
de la famille etc c'est le fruit de tout
ça j'ai pas être travaillé seul j'ai
travaillé avec deux autres journalistes
Alexis Abdelkrim kebas et puis Victor
Lefebvre qui est un autre journaliste de
factuels un ancien de Figaro live pour
tout vous dire vous avez donc accès au
dossier ce qui est très intéressant
Stéphane dans justement cette cette
enquête c'est de voir toutes les
dysfonctionnements et les scandales dans
ces dysfonctionnements et
un premier dysfonctionnement c'est que
en fait le
sur Twitter notamment et le pire c'est
que c'est signalé par les plateformes
c'est repérer par signaler par les
services spécialisés mais ils ne se
passe strictement rien strictement rien
c'est à dire que l'assassin de Samuel
Paty c'est un candidat au jihad qui
habite Évreux qui a soif de passer à
l'acte qui qui a déjà pris contact avec
quelques chefs de guerre en Syrie à
Idlib pour être précis c'est quelqu'un
qui commence à pratiquer le jihad verbal
déjà les semaines précédentes
ne sont pas sage à l'acte et d'ailleurs
quelques jours auparavant avant de s'en
prendre à Samuel Paty avant de fomenter
son cou contre sa mère panty et Patty il
veut faire la peau d'un garçon qui sur
une autre un autre réseau social je
crois que snapchat à son prix à une
jeune musulmane et il lui a demandé de
se dévoiler et il se trouve qu'il s'est
mis en tête de d'aller régler son son
et puis en fait ça lui passe et il
entend parler de l'affaire ce qui
commence à à défrayer les réseaux
sociaux
un professeur aurait foutu à la porte du
du collège du bois d'Olmes une élève
parce qu'elle a refusé de regarder les
caricatures et refuser de sortir les de
son propre cours c'est de sa part d'une
fake news épouvantable puisque cette
gamine on va savoir que c'est une petite
menteuse c'est qu'elle c'est un élève
problématique elle a déjà 11
inscriptions sur son cahier de
correspondance bref c'est un c'est une
c'est une jeune fille dont on aurait dû
se méfier de ses propos il y a eu un
précédent l'année précédente enfin bref
tout ça pour vous dire que
et bien on aurait dû le cibler lui aussi
depuis longtemps là vous en arrivez en
racontant justement bien ce qui se passe
autour de cet élève et du récit de faux
de cet élève
le deuxième dysfonctionnement il est
très frappant de le voir c'est en tout
cas le plus qu'un fonctionnement c'est
vraiment un choc c'est la
désolidarisation des collègues quand le
professeur est mis en cause donc par le
père de cette de cet élève père qui
lui-même vous le rappelez un passé
judiciaire chargé et
en plus ce qui se joue d'un activiste
islamiste exactement le père est il a
déjà fait parler de lui c'est un
personnage assez colérique qui ce qui
c'est un petit peu
sans gêne dès qu'il a un problème il
veut voir tout de suite la directrice et
il se permet d'engueuler tout le monde
il traite sa melpathie de voyou avant
même de l'avoir même devenu quand la
principale d'ailleurs proposera de
rencontrer Samuel Paty à cet homme il
dira jamais je n'irai voir un tel voyou
alors évidemment on pourrait être se
dire que les collègues de Samuel Paty
aurait dû faire pleure preuve d'un peu
plus de solidarité alors certains voilà
preuve de solidarité vous le rappelez
oui on a on a réussi à avoir quelques
témoignages de deux d'entre eux les
autres te parlent pas ils ont pas
tellement envie de parler et on comprend
pourquoi en lisant ce livre d'ailleurs
alors et pardonnez-moi je voudrais juste
rajouter un petit mot sur les
responsabilités policières parce qu'il y
a le renseignement qui ne voit pas venir
les choses
de Stéphane Simon c'est comme il est
journaliste et en plus des réponses il
peut vous apporter les questions désolé
non avant ça je voulais quand même
revenir sur les sur les sur justement
les profs parce que je demande s'il y a
pas justement un problème dans le
fonctionnement dans le même de
l'éducation nationale
[Musique]
me dérange pas ce qui les dérange c'est
qu'il y a énormément de menaces sur le
collège finalement et donc il aurait
mieux fallu ne faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de bazar pas de vagues ça c'est
quelque chose de très important
vous mettez en cause l'éducation
nationale aussi et notamment le rectorat
pourtant quand on vous lit on se dit il
fait quand même son job il y a aucun qui
justement va dans le sens de ces
professeurs il quand même il se
préoccupe il défendent sa mule moi j'en
veux si vous voulez à je suis fils de
prof petit fils de prof arrière
petit-fils de prof et c'est beaucoup
pour ça que je me suis senti concerné
par l'affaire Patty parce que j'ai
vraiment le jour de sa mort senti comme
comme si c'était quelqu'un de ma famille
au sens le plus large qui soit qui avait
été décapité je me suis immédiatement
demandé comment c'était possible alors
que mes grands-parents eux en vendaient
avec connu des conditions de travail
difficiles il représentait la République
face aux jeunes chouans entre guillemets
mes arrières grands-parents mais jamais
une scène d'horreur aurait eu lieu comme
ça
et donc
j'ai un peu digressé là pour le coup et
et pardon de l'avoir fait parce que j'ai
j'ai oublié le début de votre question
je suis désolé non mais c'est sur le
rectorat et l'éducation nationale parce
qu'on avait l'impression que justement
alors il y avait eu un achat au niveau
administratif mais il y a pas de la
charge au niveau administratif alors il
y a pas de la charge peut-être moi je je
suis un tout petit peu plus nuancé je
dirais que il y a une procédure qui a
été mise en place qui est très lourde et
que voilà il y a un problème de
procédure il y a deux niveaux d'une part
dans la procédure d'alerte il faut
cocher des cases il faut envoyer des
mails il faut alerter X Y Z tout ça est
très lourd très compliqué et si la
principale fait à peu près correctement
les choses il n'empêche que rien ne se
passe et ça c'est problématique alors il
y aura des alertes qui remontent au
ministère et c'est là aussi que c'est
préoccupant on sait que à quel point
Jean-Michel Blanquer a été soucieux de
réaffirmer les valeurs de la République
la laïcité au sein de l'école mais
toutes ces procédures qu'il a mis en
place place et bien elle conduisent à
une situation ubues que je vous résume
très simplement c'est notre entretien
d'ailleurs avec Jean-Michel Blanquer il
me dit je n'ai entendu parler de Samuel
Patty que le jour de sa mort je lui dis
oui mais il y a eu des alertes qui sont
remontés quand même à votre cabinet à
votre ministère et oui mais des alertes
on en a entre 30 et 40 par jour on peut
pas tous les les suivre quand même et là
c'est problématique vous en conviendrez
parce que à quoi sert de faire autant
d'alerte si il y a pas les moyens
humains et techniques en face pour les
traiter
on y revenait vous en parliez tout à
l'heure il y a quelque chose également
de très choquant
c'est le renseignement territorial qui
ignore le danger
alors au moment où l'affaire est en
train de prendre des proportions
incroyables sur le sur les réseaux
sociaux au moment où la mosquée de
Pantin notamment partage les vidéos de
Brahim schnina et de ses friwok le père
de le père de la jeune fille et que
l'activiste présente comme étant le
représentant des imams de France
totalement mythomane il est représentant
que de lui-même mais c'est un activiste
assez connu fichier s depuis années
depuis longtemps activiste de islamiste
depuis les années 80 bref au moment où
le danger se précise au moment où il y a
de plus en plus de menaces qui remontent
sur le répondeur téléphonique de
l'établissement des mails etc etc et
bien vous avez une principale qui fait
son essai meilleures efforts pour que on
fasse quelque chose pour pour la
sécurité de l'établissement et puis vous
avez des renseignements territoriaux qui
disent les affaires sont en cours et qui
m'ignorent également la portée de ce que
peuvent entraîner ces islamistes là qui
sont bon ben un peu connus déjà depuis
longtemps qui sont des Grandes Gueules
mais il y aura pas grand chose à faire
sauf qu'ils ont complètement oublié que
dans le spectre numérique et ben il y a
Enzo Rohff il y aurait pu avoir beaucoup
d'autres personnes et ça va juste donc
il y a ce problème là qui est donc un
problème terrible et tout à l'heure vous
parliez aussi des failles du
renseignement c'est que Enzo Rohff qui a
été signalé jusqu'à quatre fois le
week-end précédent et bien
là aussi on ne traite pas les
signalements sur la plateforme Pharos ça
aurait été simple de sauver la vie si
vous me permettez de conclure comme ça
et de Samuel Paty parce que il suffisait
de prendre la décision de ce qu'on
appelle une décision d'éloignement
c'est-à-dire que ça mêle pastille
n'aille plus au travail on est une
semaine avant les vacances mais lui il a
pas demandé non plus cette protection
mais c'est pas c'est renseignement en
France c'est tout à fait rapide et
discrétionnaire et sans formalisme il
suffit que les renseignements 17
personnes et menacées on peut l'extraire
et lui demander de d'être éloigné on
peut aussi convenir que on aurait pu
devant la montée des périls prendre une
protection policière pour Samuel Paty et
ça ça relève de la décision du ministère
de l'intérieur ça n'a pas été fait non
plus Stéphane un autre point un autre
dysfonctionnement qui est très frappant
dans votre livre c'est autour du cas de
la famille Enzo Rohff ce statut de
réfugié politique alors que quand le
corps revient en Tchétchénie il est
célébré
est-ce que j'ai découvert avec
stupéfaction c'est que le président
Macron est une fois que le corps est
rapatrié en Tchétchénie le corps est
célébré le père donnera une interview
dans
une influenceurs ça vaut le peu de son
pesant d'ordre dans lequel il explique
que son fils est un bon fils parce qu'il
a fait ce qu'il avait à faire et puis le
double discours de la famille double
discours total et puis ils estiment que
finalement si ce drame a eu lieu ces
deux la faute du président Macron
il y aura incroyable
réponse courte sur la personnalité de
Samuel Paty qu'est-ce que vous avez
appris donc j'ai appris que c'est
quelqu'un de discret de tendre ce que
c'était un laïc apaisé c'était quelqu'un
de discret mais très investi dans son
travail quelqu'un qui voulait faire des
cours très interactif alors par exemple
il est pour faire pour sa fameuse
journée situation dilemme être ou ne pas
être Charlie il fait un trait sur le mur
et puis de mettre les arguments pour les
arguments contre il fait vivre son cours
c'est pour ça qu'il est allé même
chercher sur le réseau canopé qui est un
réseau de l'éducation nationale les
caricatures qui sont du matériel
pédagogique à la disposition de tous
c'est quelqu'un qui veut améliorer les
choses et c'est donc un c'est ce qu'on
appelle un prof anonyme mes bras et bon
voilà et un prof qu'on aurait aimé avoir
entre guillemets il y aura un procès il
y aura certainement même deux procès il
y en a un grand celui sur les
responsabilités et les complicités qui
aura lieu donc début 2024 avec une
partie il y a 14 personnes qui seront
qui sont mises en cause et qui vont être
jugés dont 6 adolescents donc ça veut
dire qu'il y aura un procès à huis clos
et une partie à huis clos et une partie
de débat public où là on aura les
complices directs ceux qui ont été
fournir avec avec on the Rohff les armes
du crime et puis après il y a une autre
affaire qu'il faut suivre suite à la
plainte de mettre Virginie Leroy sur
l'omission de porter secours ou là c'est
les responsabilités de l'État qui vont
être pointés c'est une affaire qui est
instruite actuellement et qui va falloir
suivre de très près et en la suivra bien
entendu et vous les rappelez vous
rappelez d'ailleurs vous faites le
portrait de toutes ces personnes à la
fin de votre ouvrage c'est absolument
passionnant les derniers jours de Samuel
Paty c'est bien sûr un livre à lire et
c'est aux éditions plomb et puis je
rappelle également aux autres publicités
le petit dernier ça c'est sur le net et
puis bien entendu Front populaire on en
a parlé dernièrement avec Michel Onfray
dans ce studio merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup on se retrouve très vite pour
un nouveau numéro de point de vue
[Musique]